[Music]
[Applause]
bringing Jeff Patterson the Major League
Baseball Insider for the mothership what
happened yesterday or last night that
all of a sudden Carlos Correa is a
member of the New York Mets
I'm still trying to figure out the
details Dan but I think the the sketch
looks like this Carlos Correa had agreed
to a 13-year 350 million dollar deal
with the San Francisco Giants such
agreements of course are pending
physical examination in the physical
examination something came up I don't
know what specifically at this point
that spooked the Giants and uh when that
deal seemingly fell apart Steve Cohen
the New York Mets owner who had at the
11th hour prior to correa's agreement
with the Giants talked with Correa about
a potential deal rekindled things with
Scott Boris correa's agent and over the
course of the next five or so hours they
hammered out a 12-year 315 million
dollar deal that took the Mets payroll
to the cusp of 500 million dollars and
it would be the most expensive team in
North American professional sports
history the Mets have uh if Korea passes
uh the physical which he is expected to
do at this point of course wait wait
wait wait hold a hundred million dollars
I think so the medical issue that the
Giants brought up is not going to be a
medical issue with the Mets
one would presume if Steve Cohen's going
on the record with the New York Post
talking about how Carlos Correa is the
missing piece now maybe doctors go to
him and say no no no no no you can't do
this I mean we already saw that happen
with a 350 million dollar contract uh
but you know this sounds like cold feet
Jeff this strikes me as do you really
want to go to the Giants there's not
much here uh you know Wonderful
franchise wonderful City great fan base
do you really want to go here
foreign
why would you agree in the first place I
don't I don't well because the money you
couldn't turn it down Scott Morris
doesn't go for the second best offer
it's always the best offer and you're
going to turn down 350 million dollars
now you just signed for what 13 for 315
or whatever it is feels like just feels
like
Carlos Correa may have said to Scott
Boris you know what I just don't feel
this doesn't feel right this isn't where
I want to be because if if I'm going to
buy a house but I can't inspect it but
it's going to cost me 300 million
dollars or there's an issue but I don't
know exactly what it is
I would have some concerns about that
this just feels like it's cold feet on
Carlos Correa
that I do not know at this point I will
say this though
um the the medical evaluation process
it's it's complicated you know guys go
through MRIs they get blood work done
stuff comes up like this sort of thing
happens probably a little more
frequently than the public realizes
because behind the scenes there can be
renegotiation on the deal and you know
if there's any cold feet maybe it came
after the giant said hey we have an
issue we have a problem here and then at
that point all bets are off
is Steve Cohen spending intelligently as
the Mets owner no
[Laughter]
or that that's necessary for winning no
he's spending like the richest owner in
Major League Baseball should spend
according to fans now generally speaking
what fans want is not gone out and
exercised by their owner but Steve Cohen
is changing the Paradigm there Dan we
have to understand he bought the New
York Mets as a giant New York Mets fan
and he is running the New York Mets like
a giant New York Mets fan he spent 800
plus million dollars in free agency this
off-season bringing in Justin Verlander
bringing back Brandon Nimo and Edwin
Diaz this is the fourth nine-figure
contract if it gets done that the Mets
will have done this off-season alone
they've already got Peter Lonzo they've
got Francisco Lindor they've got
Starling Marte and Max Scherzer and
Carlos Carrasco and kodai Sanga and Jose
cantana and I can go on and on and on
about all the talent that the New York
Mets have and on paper considering that
they you know 101 games last year they
are the presumed favorite in the Amer or
in the National League East rather but
let's not forget the 2021 World Series
champion Atlanta Braves still in the NL
East the 2022 National League champion
Philadelphia Phillies still in the
National League East and with Trey
Turner added to that team along with
Taiwan Walker so it's not like the Mets
are gonna win the NL East running away
at this point or that they're such
overwhelming favorites no this is a
better Mets team than there was last
year but uh is it a team that's uh a 500
million dollar Talent team you know I
wouldn't quite go there yet the World
Series odds according to DraftKings the
Astros are still the favorites then it's
the Yankees and the Mets and then it's
the Dodgers after that I'll leave you
with this speaking of the Dodgers given
what happened with Carlos Correa playing
with the Astros would Dodger fans have
accepted Carlos Correa
if the Dodgers went out and signed him
you know I think that
the second Carlos Correa hit the first
big home run in a Los Angeles Dodgers
uniform they would love him because
that's how fans are it's all about what
you do in our laundry okay but Carlos
Correa is not going to be hitting any
home runs in Dodger uniform dad uh if
everything goes as expected and we know
things sometimes don't go as expected
but if everything goes as expected he
will be a New York Met and a New York
Met third baseman for a long time always
great to talk to you Jeff thank you
pleasure as always my Dan thanks for
having me Jeff pouncin Baseball Insider
for the Mothership